hey everyone bandit here have you heard
the legend the legend of the living
traveling inanimate object with a
warrior's heart and gentleman's
character that longs for the thrill of
combat if you spent any time at all
looking at the characters of eldon ring
you've probably come across the giant
living warrior known as alexander the
jar alexander is truly the siegward of
katarina of this game and just like the
warrior onion the warrior jar also has
determination that comes from elements
outside our knowledge and also has a
rather tragic ending to his story but
what is his story where did he come from
and why is he unrelentingly venturing
across the land in search of combat i'm
so glad you asked because surprise
surprise you just so happened to click
on alexander's story explained video
which is a video that will explain
alexander's story in a way that anyone
can understand and which also just so
happens to have spoilers in it just
saying you've been warned the segment of
alexander's store that we can play
through in-game isn't really that
complex but allow me to recap it here so
that everyone's on the same page when
you meet alexander in the game you first
come across the thick boy halfway stuck
in the ground and upon your meeting he
will ask you to smack his hind quarters
as hard as you can to pop him out of his
sedentary prison after you pop him out
with a good walloper five he once again
introduces himself as iron fist
alexander and explains that he is on his
way to red main castle in the far
southeast in order to further his
education in the ways of war which is
exactly what he does you meet up with
him again deion
in said red castle and he's gearing up
to take part in the festival you know
that big happy party that's thrown once
every so often to try to recruit heroes
of the land to kill the rampaging
general radon alexander states that he
is excited to take on the legendary
warrior and is one of the spirits you
can summon in the battle after you
defeat the big guy on your 20th attempt
or so you can find alexander nearby
shuffling around in the dirt you talk to
him and he states that he was wounded by
ridin and then hid for the rest of the
fight something that he is ashamed of
but then he says he hasn't given up on
getting stronger yet and explains that
he's trying to stuff the bodies of other
warriors from the shattering war that
died there in that spot down into his
body in order to level up his strength
stat or something ironically it's
implied that he even stuffs the body of
star scourge radan himself into him
since if you're a monster and you kill
alexander before this point in time he
drops the warrior jar shard which states
that it's made from the relics of
ancient warriors also confirming that he
stuffs ancient warrior bodies into
himself however if you kill him after
his quest is over he drops the shard of
alexander instead which adds some info
and says that some of the relics were
from a red-haired champion since we've
seen him scooping up the bodies around
radan's battleground it's pretty much
confirmed that at this point he was
indeed dumping some pieces of radan into
himself probably his head anyway after
the somewhat disturbing battleground
scene you then leave him and find him
once again stuck in a hole and after
oiling him up and helping him out again
he mentions that he fell into that
blasted hole because he was trying to
catch a glimpse of his home the home
that he vowed to never return to but
we'll get to that in a sec he mentions
he's heading up to the fiery mountain in
the north to bake himself into something
harder by way of lava and when you also
head that way you find him just chilling
in the middle of actual molten rock
yelling a bit out of pain but otherwise
doing pretty well he notices you and
gifts you with a jar of your very own to
wear on your head something he crafted
for you as a token of his friendship
then he says this fire ain't hot enough
it's just lukewarm and that he's going
to instead go temper himself in the
legendary fires of the flame of ruin
which for you lore experts out there
should sound pretty familiar and this is
why you can then summon him again for
the fight against the fire giant who was
guarding the flame of ruin before you
killed him after which you now have
access to said flame of ruin and
apparently using the flame transports
you to the timeless city held in midair
called the crumbling pharaoh missoula
because whether you let melana light the
flame using her body as kindling or you
do it yourself in the path of the
frenzied flame you end up in fair
missoula either way meaning doing this
equals portal to here anyway apparently
alexander also tried to use the frenzied
flame to temper himself because you run
into him up there but this unfortunately
marks the last time your paths will
cross because his path ends here you see
the whole time you've been meeting up
with alexander at different points in
the game he always says that he wants to
fight stronger champions in order to
become stronger himself right but the
strongest champion he's ever seen is
standing right in front of him it's you
so he formally asks you if you would do
him the honor of facing him in mortal
combat which ends of course with your
victory after the battle lying on the
ground moments from death he says he
knew he never really stood a chance
against you but that he was glad he got
to go out the warrior's way and with one
last hearty chuckle he shatters
completely leaving behind the shard of
alexander that i spoke about earlier and
a bloody clump of his insides and while
this marks the tragic end of iron fist
alexander's story what about its
beginning is there any way to find out
more about where he came from and why he
was so obsessed with becoming a strong
warrior absolutely there is if you
travel to the eastern region of lyonia
at the bottom of a cliff that is much
too tall for any normal being to descend
without carefully stepping from one
outcrop to the next you will find a
hidden village that is not accessible
any other way this quaint little village
is called jarburg and it is the home of
the living jars that alexander came from
and vowed to never return to but unlike
the other soul jars you come across in
the game that either try to punch you or
blow you up or otherwise end your
existence the jars of jarburg are all
100 friendly docile and town right
adorable citizens of the lands between
you'll find them lying about idly
chatting with one another and even
dancing around flowers they're so cute
one of these jars in particular is a
youth named jar baron who you can
actually walk up to and speak with the
little jar affectionately refers to you
as cuz short for cousin and asks if
you're there to be the new potentate of
jarburg potentate means leader by the
way but will then deny you your potency
on account of your not having smooth
hands i should have been using lotion
before too long jar baron will ask you
if you've met uncle alexander and will
then explain to you that alexander used
to live there in jarburg but then left
to become a champion and insisted that
the path of the champion must be taken
alone and in classic alexander fashion
vowed to never again return home his
bravery and heroic ambition inspired the
little jar baron who admits to you
secretly that he too is a warrior jar
and one day will also leave the village
to become strong just like his uncle
alexander please don't tell anyone cuz
but
i'm actually a warrior jar as well but
why should these jars living in
essentially jar heaven leave are they
just getting bored well possibly but jar
baron also gives us some insight into
this question he eventually asks you if
you've heard of the poachers who hunt
down living jars and smash them up for
their pieces this is actually the very
reason that the jars established the
little isolated town of jarburg it's
kept hidden in secret and out of general
knowledge so that the poachers won't
find them and will therefore let them be
jar baron says that he hopes alexander
will beat them all up which implies that
this might have been the reason for
alexander's quest of trial by combat you
see as you could imagine these little
living jars are quite special they're
magical and according to what we can
read about the description of the
lookalike cracked and ritual pots the
materials of the jars themselves can
literally mend when broken literally
giving them the name living jars this
makes the jar's material quite valuable
and able to be used to make various
different magically augmented
concoctions now how the jars came into
existence in the first place isn't
something that's confirmed in the game
but we can speculate a couple different
theories on the subject for instance we
know that before ratigan's rise to power
as king there were coliseums scattered
throughout the lands between that house
you know combat stuff ritualistic
warfare done in reverence and honor of
the erd tree and right outside the
coliseum of caled is a colossal warrior
jar called the great jar we also see
loads of empty or broken jars around
several different minor herb trees and
the jar's lids are always ordained with
depictions of the earth tree and the
roots of the earth tree are shown to be
feeding off of the bodies of dead humans
which is a whole other rabbit hole of
lore that we don't have time to get into
at this point but to add to this point
when you die in the game a sprout of a
golden tree an erd tree appears at the
spot where you died until you collect
your runes from it implying that the erd
trees themselves live off of death it
could be that since america removed the
rune of death and therefore natural
death itself from the world as part of
her golden order the jars were created
to bring the bodies of warrior who fell
in the ritual combat of the coliseums to
the minor herb trees in order to provide
nourishment to the new tree sprouts and
recycle them into grace for the rest of
the citizens of the lands between a
method of cycling life under queen
merica the eternal like i said though
this is just one of a few different
theories of how the living jars came to
be all of which are pretty speculative
so for the time being i digress back on
topic though even if the soul jars were
potentially created as a way to house
the dead and water the earth trees why
are they being poached for their
materials is business really just that
good right now well i'm inclined to say
no seeing as merchants that we can find
throughout the lands between haven't
seen a customer in ages on the other
hand ages ago there was this little war
called the shattering in the war several
things which were previously outlawed or
shunned were brought into focus and
exploited for the purposes of war such
as the art of making weaponized perfume
also known as aromatics the war led to a
bunch of perfumers being drafted into
combat and therefore made this practice
a widely exploited tactic and led to the
rise and demand of certain types of
perfumes such as the spark and iron jar
aromatics the iron jar aromatic is a bit
unique because not only does it raise a
user's poise while rendering them more
vulnerable to lightning but just like
the name implies it is made through use
of shards of living jars which means
that jars have to be killed and
harvested in order for these to be made
it says write in the description that
perfumers are plainly in league with jar
poachers this means that essentially
jars became hunted for their bodies as a
result of the shattering war and as a
result of being hunted most of the soul
jars then decided that they would make
use of the warrior bodies within them
and become warriors themselves and would
fight back against those who would do
them harm which is why you find them in
deep dark crypts and other hiding places
where they're hostile towards you when
otherwise they used to be peaceful
before the war they simply want to live
and don't know whether your friend or
phone decide to attack you before they
themselves are attacked this is what led
to the jars escaping and finding and
founding the isolated town of jarburg
where they could live peacefully only
unfortunately once again the story of
jarburg does not end well while you're
traveling you can stop by every now and
then and talk to jar baron and get the
latest scoop on what's going on around
town eventually you discover that that
old coward of house hoslo dialos has
come to town to be their potentate which
is something he feels will finally give
him purpose because come on how hard can
it be to look after some harmless little
jar people right well fast forward a bit
and one day you return to find everyone
smashed and killed all except for jar
baron who tells you that a poacher found
their town after all and came in to
extract their valuable skin but he
doesn't cry because he's a strong little
warrior
i won't cry though
i'm a warrior jar
a warrior
you then find dialos lying in the middle
of the road having fought off the
poacher at the cost of his own life
after the genocide of literally everyone
in jarburg aside from jar baron he
decides to take off and become a warrior
jar just like his uncle alexander you
can then give him alexander's innards
which jar baron claims he will stuff
into himself when he is worthy after
which he says goodbye and sets off never
to be seen again leaving behind the
companion jar talisman a token of his
friendship and that my friends is the
story of alexander the warrior jar and
the little town of jarburg now that
everyone's good and depressed let me
thank you for watching please leave a
like if you enjoyed this video or the
effort that i put into making it and
digging through all this sad lore and
trust me with this game every piece of
lore is painstakingly pieced together by
way of many different item descriptions
and subscribe if you haven't already to
stick around for much more content and
to avenge the deaths of the jars of
jarburg thank you as always to my bandit
crew of which i am honored to welcome
cindy h into you guys always cheer me up
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day this is bandit looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out and hey go watch a funny
movie or spongebob or something like
that to cheer up peace
[Music]
you